[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mans
encore et je suis ravi de vous voir ou
de vous revoir ici pour une nouvelle
vidéo alors aujourd'hui on va parler de
films de mariage
et pour ça je vais vous raconter une
histoire comment j'en suis venu à en
faire pourquoi j'adore ça et surtout
pourquoi vous pourriez sérieusement
envisager de vous y mettre aussi après
avoir regardé cette vidéo en entier à et
pour ceux qui veulent connaître la
grande nouvelle que je tisse depuis des
semaines sur installer sur les autres
réseaux
c'est à la fin de la vidéo j'ai fait un
petit chapitre al vous allez voir c'est
super intéressant
alors dans cette histoire on revient en
arrière de quatre ans et vous êtes en
face d'eux françois ici présentes qui
vient de tout plaquer pour vivre de sa
passion c'est à dire la vidéo mais qui
se heurte déjà à un premier obstacle qui
va bien pouvoir vouloir de ces vidéos
alors je fais deux trois plans corpo à
l'époque mais bon rien de stable surtout
zéro visibilité sur l'avenir et la genre
il ya un destin je vois passer dans mon
fils facebook une vidéo sponsorisés d'un
film de mariage
et bizarrement j'ai trouvé ça ouf le
storytelling la prod la colo je regarde
le truc et je suis totalement sur le
cloud mais genre vraiment quoi je kiffe
et à ce moment-là je me dis non mais
françois tu vas pas faire du film de
mariage quand même tu y connais rien en
mariage n'a jamais fait ça et puis du
mariage quoi tu vas en faire deux trois
et après tu vas te saouler mais bon
est-ce que j'avais vraiment le choix
à l'époque pas vraiment alors je même
creusé la tête pour essayer de trouver
comment trouver un contrat de ce type
mais lâcher comme ça sans jamais l'avoir
fait c'est plutôt chaud est resté bien
jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo parce que
vous allez voir que je vous ai
totalement mâcher le travail mais ça on
le voit un petit peu là et je me répète
mais à ce moment là j'avais strictement
aucune idée de comment m'y prendre
mais vraiment bref je vais voir un pote
photographe de mariage et je lui demande
s'ils proposent de la vidéo il me dit qu
no et moi de mon côté je lui dis que
j'aimerais bien et c est là bingo il
propose ça à un couple de mariés et
quelques jours plus tard je leur propose
le deal suivant
vu que j'ai rien à montrer et que je
suis nouveau je leur fais un teaser oui
parce qu'entre temps j'ai appris qu'il y
avait des teasers de mariage
une version courte et des films ce
teaser le fait gratuitement et je ferai
également un film le film je leur
montrerai le résultat est si leur plaît
ils pourront l'acheter mais sans
obligation genre s'ils le veulent pas
pas de souci je le garde
et bah ils ont dit oui et déjà c'est
super cool parce qu'ils m'ont fait
confiance même s'ils avaient rien à
perdre pour le coup puisque dans tous
les cas ça pouvait être que du gratuit
si vous voulez et rien que ça j'ai vu un
truc qui m'a plu c'est que les mariés
ils font confiance
il ya un rapport humain et c'est
important pour eux et ils te confie
quand même ça ce qui est quand même
plutôt cool et déjà j'ai eu le sentiment
de faire un truc utile et si je me
démerde et bien va peut-être créer de
l'émotion choses que je ne pouvais pas
vraiment faire trop dans le film corpo
dogbo françois tous contents il a sous
contrat niveau contrat je faisais bien
là mais ça j'ai appris au fil du temps
comme ce fameux truc que je vais vous
montrer en fin de vidéo pour que vous
gagneriez pas comme moi et là du coup je
commence à écumer les groupes facebook
les sites de prestataires de mariage
je regarde ce qui se fait un peu plus en
détails pour essayer de construire un
petit peu mon film et je me rends compte
qu'il ya énormément de variété dans les
films de mariage
et là je vois un truc c'est qu'il ya
même des choses pêcher plutôt
rock'n'roll
parce qu'à la base pour moi le film de
mariage c'était des violons des je
t'aime
voilà tout est beau tout est gentil
bisounours de l'amour là c'est sympa
mais bon c'est pas vraiment ma came et
là j'ai eu la seconde illuminations par
rapport au film mariage c'est que on
peut se faire carrément me plaisent et
être hyper créatif c'est pas parce que
c'est un mariage que je dois tout
changer dans ce que je fais et je me dis
mais c'est trop bien franchement je vais
pouvoir faire des trucs vraiment
vraiment cool alors je fais mes devoirs
je prépare le truc et le jour j arrive
et là comment vous dire j'ai souffert
j'étais clairement pas préparé à ce que
ce soit aussi physique je filmais tous
heureusement mari et elle en 2d shooter
mais je courais partout pour essayer de
tout choper je savais pas du tout quoi
prioriser je suivais mon pote
photographes mais je savais mais alors
pas du tout où j'allais à 18 heures
j'en peux plus mais je me dis que c'est
bientôt fini mais non en fait en fait
j'étais tellement pas préparés que
j'avais même pas posé la question de
savoir si on restait le soir et le
couple étant tellement gentils nous
avait prévu un repas et tout donc on est
resté le soir elle a déjà tous mes
préjugés sur les vidéastes de mariage
avait totalement volé en éclats quand tu
vois l'énergie que sa demande que tu
fais à la fois cadreur chef op
preneur de son responsable éclairage
pointer là tu te dis que les vidéastes
de mariage c'est pas des vidéastes bas
de gamme comme certains peuvent se
l'imaginer et même j'ai envie de dire
bien au contraire c'est assez cool alors
une fois fini j'étais totalement épuisé
en rentrant mais j'ai pas résisté j'ai
des rochers et vers 5h du mat j'avais
sorti un teaser à peu près monté après
je me suis instantanément endormi
évidemment et le lendemain je peaufine
mon teaser est tellement de près c'est
d'avoir le retour des mariés je me dis
allez soyons fous j'en vois hélas pas de
réponse
j'attends rien bon maintenant je sais
que généralement le lendemain d'un
mariage les mariés se propose un petit
peu voient ils dorment
parce que c'est quand même relativement
épuisant que c'était normal mais
seulement je me disais c'est peut-être
nul des tests mais merde merde et pas du
tout coup de fil quelques heures plus
tard le temps qu'ils sortent du cirage
un petit peu pour me dire qu'ils avaient
adoré avec une voix super émue au
téléphone et là j'ai découvert le truc
que j'adore le plus dans le mariage
c'est l'émotion des mariés quand on leur
montre le film je vous la fait courte
mais ils ont visionné le film complet
ils l'ont acheté et c'est d'ailleurs là
que j'ai découvert un autre aspect
plutôt cool dans le film de mariage
c'est que ça paye bien quand même
franchement en toute transparence mon
panier moyen pour un mariage cette année
c'est environ 3000 euros et je suis
booké plus d'un an à l'avancé
donc à vous de voir mais moi je pense
que vous devriez sérieusement envisagé
le film de mariage
si vous vous lancez ou si vous avez
envie de vous lancer ou même si vous
faites déjà des vidéos depuis longtemps
mais que vous n'avez jamais tenté ce
type de film là parce que vraiment
vraiment après tout ce que je vous ai
raconté pour rendre compte que c'est
cool et justement on en arrive à cette
fameuse nouvelle le gros truc si vous me
suivez sur instagram vous le savez
probablement c'est que aujourd'hui je
lance ma formation mariage sur u10 cette
formation je bosse dessus depuis à peu
près un an et ça a été un boulot de
malade et j'ai voulu y mettre absolument
de tout ce que j'ai pas eue quand je me
suis lancé je ne suis vraiment pas foutu
vous niveau contenu c'est totalement
ouf vous allez voir donc dans cette
formation vous trouverez les choses
suivantes il ya 90
module vidéo soit plus de cinq heures de
formation pour vous apprendre tout ce
que je sais sur le film de mariage et
quand je dis tout c'est tout il ya aussi
du bien aussi d'un du making of d'un
vrai mariage pour voir tout ce que je
fais et comment je le fais mari m'a
filmé toute une journée de mariage et je
vous montre pour vous expliquer avec des
exemples concrets
il ya aussi mes documents de travail la
short list mon flyers les questionnaires
marié les tarifs les contrats je vous
explique aussi les prix que je pratique
et comment les fixes et ensuite il ya
toutes les étapes pour savoir comment
trouver vos premiers contrats comment
préparer le tournage tout ce qu'il ya à
savoir le jour du tournage le montage la
post production jusqu'à la livraison de
votre film bref je vous donne tout ce
que j'ai dû apprendre quand même au
cours des années passées
ça a été énormément de ta fais ça je
vous le donne dans cette formation en
parlant prix à coûte 199 euros mais pour
le lancement elle est en promo de 30% en
suivant le lien qui se situe en
descriptions et d'ailleurs pour fêter ce
gros événement tout ce que je propose
est en promo la formation final cut les
luttes les préceptes tout est en promo
pour trois semaines en descriptions
alors je sais que c'est pas rien comme
somme mais franchement avec tout ce
qu'il ya dedans il n'y a aucune raison
que vous ne vous l'a remboursiez pas
genre 3,4 fois voire même plus rien
qu'avec la première prestation que vous
allez dégoter avec et j'ai aucun doute
sur le fait que vous en trouviez et ça
c'est une bonne raison pour mettre le
coup deux blaster sur le pouce en l'air
qui situe juste en dessous de cette
vidéo mais aussi pour poursuivre le
visionnage en allant sur cette vidéo qui
s'affiche sur le jour où j'ai failli
perdre tous mes fichiers sur un mariage
je pense que ça va pouvoir vous aider
aussi